Hello everybody... Sorry, I got to do the croaky greeting, the caw-caw!
Sorry, no, that's not the croaky greeting, this is the croaky greeting.
Hello everybody, and welcome to JustCrowThings, where I, Croaky, am gonna play a crow game.
I need you guys to know, the amount of people that, like, added me for this game, like, even my staff members were, like, adding me, and was like, oh my god, you gotta play this game.
They were like, this game is awesome!
This game reminded me of Croaky, and I was like, I guess it's time, it's time to bring out Croaky.
Free Croaky from the closet.
It's locked in the closet till it was croaky time.
Okay, so also, by the way guys, um, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but, like, every day, almost every stream, the last, like, one, two, three, four, five streams, I've been playing around with my stream settings.
So, like, if my streams have been, like, super fucking weird, it's because every day, for the last, like, five streams, it's been different stream settings.
Yeah, my ocean is in 1440p!
Snoop's leaving the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Because I realized, I was like, wait, this looks, okay, I was like, my streams have been looking really weird lately.
I think it's because of my new CPU.
I noticed, like, um, yeah, I've been fucking freestyling.
That's why, like, my streams have been, like, super wonky.
Like, I've been, like, fucking around with bitrate.
I've been fucking around with stream settings.
And I was like, oh, how do I stream in 1440p?
Maybe that will fix it.
And then I noticed, like, Wukong, the Wukong, when I was streaming Wukong game, it was extra crunchy.
So, I was, like, trying to figure it out.
I was like, how the fuck, how do I fix this?
How do I?
Why is it so?
Why is it so crunch?
Oh, shit.
Okay, no, I don't want to listen to this.
I was like, why is it so crunchy?
So, so, every, so, like, I think I figured it out.
I don't know if I actually did, though.
But, like, maybe we're doing 1440p.
Um, it will be different.
But, yes, I finally, I figured out how to do 1440p.
Um, I'm not sure if that will fix the crunchy, bitrate, the crunchiness of everything.
Um, at one point, I was even, like, what if I just do 18,000 bitrate?
Like, I, I have, I have the internet for it.
Like, what if, what if, what if you ate, but then it didn't work.
It, like, I had, like, weird-ass stutters.
So, I was, like, like, I had, like, stream stutters.
But, I was, like, is that because of the game?
Or because I put too much bitrate?
So, now I'm back at, um, I'm back at 13k bitrate.
But, like, I figured out how to do 1440p.
So, like, maybe it'll look, does my stream look better?
I don't, I don't know.
Isn't it?
Oh, my God.
I think Croaky deserves to be at 1440p.
So, like, I hope the quality, like, improves.
I even did, like, uh, yeah, too much bitrate is bad.
Yeah, I noticed that.
Because I was, like, maybe if I up the bitrate for Wukong, it'll be less crunchy.
Because people were commenting.
Were, like, up your bitrate, Doki!
Up it!
And I was, like, why are you yelling at me?
I'm Croaky.
I was, like, I was, like, why are you yelling at me?
I'm just a bird.
But, but, yeah.
So, like, I lowered.
I lowered the bitrate back to the 13k bitrate.
And then unlocked 1440p.
To be a little.
I'm just a little crow.
I'm just.
Front-facing Croaky won't hurt you.
Don't worry.
Front-facing Croaky isn't real.
Front-facing Croaky won't hurt you.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
It's, like, it's, like, Phineas and Ferb.
Front-facing Phineas won't hurt you.
Doki would definitely play.
And the prophecy is true.
Yeah!
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
But, yeah.
I hope I figured out the correct.
This is the last, like, last setting I have to play around with.
And, like, we figured it out for real this time.
So, yeah.
That's why every stream has been looking really fucked up lately.
And, like, streams have been really weird quality.
So, I feel like every, every week there's something.
Every week there's something for Doki.
Yeah.
I'm on a 1440p monitor.
This is the Croaky we needed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Reni.
Also, like, there's, like, there's, like, some stuff I like doing as Croaky.
Let me show you guys.
All right.
Yes, there's settings.
This is...
I thought this was really funny.
I was, like, playing around with, like, settings.
And then there's, like, there's, like, stuff that would make me, like, look better.
But then there was...
There's, like, graying, too.
So, we can add, like, a cinematic feel to it.
But this one's my favorite.
Ba-da-ba-da-bum.
Ba-da-bum-bum.
Ba-na-na-na.
Ba-da-na-na.
Ba-da-ba...
.
Bag tomato.
I just wanted to, I just wanted to show you guys that one.
So, like, I could actually, like, face different directions, but I figured, like, this was the best one.
There's a reason why, because I was like, what if I just streamed like this the entire time?
I was like, do I do front facing?
But then...
And also, I did not like the shadow on this side.
I feel like, I don't know.
I feel like I like the no shadow part from this side.
That's why we're facing this side today.
Yeah.
Front facing croaky can't hurt you no more.
Don't worry.
Front facing croaky will not hurt you guys.
Front facing croaky doesn't exist.
He's not real.
She's not real.
But yes, today we're gonna be crows.
I feel like that's very self explanatory.
We're gonna be, we're a crow and we're gonna play as a crow today.
Any life life updates?
Let me see.
I did write some stuff.
Oh yeah.
Dad is a menace right now.
He is a fucking menace.
He found the box that's filled with dog stuff.
Like today, I heard like rummaging outside my office.
Room.
And then I was like, what the fuck is that?
And then I went outside.
I went to the living room and I saw him like, I saw him on top of a box.
Half his body was inside the box.
And he was trying to grab toys.
Cause like, I thought it was weird.
I was like, how did he find this ball?
I thought I put away this ball in the box.
And then like, so that, but I ignored it.
I was like, Oh, maybe like, you know, maybe the bag was out.
And then he just like, got there, you know?
But then like, I realized.
And then I was like, no, wait a minute.
That's weird.
That's like weird.
And then like, I saw like, I caught him in the act and this is what I saw.
I'm going to show you a picture of what I drew the picture out.
Cause I was telling my friends about it.
I was like, what the fuck?
He's a fucking, this is what I saw.
And I was like, Dad!
Dad!
I was like, oh shit.
Like half his body was like in the box.
And he was like, trying to find his toys and stuff.
I was like, oh my God.
Like,
and then to put a box on top of the box, because, you know, I didn't want him to, I was worried.
He's going to find something, eat it.
Like, cause like, cause like dogs eat the craziest shit.
And I was like, I don't want to fucking find something and then just eat it.
Um, but he jumped on top of the box and then it was just like rummaging, rummaging it.
I was like, what the fuck are you doing?
Anyway.
Oh yeah.
But we're also here.
I can, I can do other faces too.
Give me that.
Whoa.
Is that a shiny?
Is that an Akasupa?
That's so shiny.
And I could do, hmm.
That's sus.
Hmm.
That's pretty sus, man.
And then also like, I didn't just, it's EP time.
Also, like I can't my arms out, but like my arms are tired right now.
Whoa.
Oh, sorry.
Is that an Akasupa?
Guys, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Whoa.
Is that an Akasupa?
Excuse me, is that... what you got there?
What you got there?
Whoa!
Darkblade!
Is that... whoa, is that Akasupa?
Shiny!
Darkblade, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Cookie, I've been busy and gone for a week, but I'm so happy I can return!
Be blessed to see my real...
Cookie, I love you, Cookie!
Okay, let's actually... let's actually play the game.
So yeah, that's me!
That's me!
Oh!
Whoa!
Is that another Akasupa?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wow!
Thank you for the Akasupa, media!
Thank you, thank you!
Fine, here's your Akasupa.
Look, he even looks like me!
Look!
He even looks like me!
All right, start.
I don't want to play any of the controls, but like, can't be that bad.
You're a fucking crow.
How hard can crow trolls be?
It's literally a crow.
My, my, my.
You're growing so fast, little crow.
That's me!
You make me proud to be your grandma.
I remember being young like you, so full of energy, so full of not having back pain.
Oh, no.
32!
Oh, wait, no, crows live a long time.
I forgot.
That's why, like, by the way, like, don't own birds because, like, especially, like, bigger form of birds, like cockatiels and shit, because they live for a very long time.
Like, you think, like, oh, yeah, they'll live, like, you know, like, dogs and cats, like, short lifespan.
No, they're, like, their lifespans are, like, adults.
Like...
Like, their lifespans are, like, people.
Like, some cockatiels can live up to 60 plus years old.
So, like, it's literally a child.
But who doesn't go to college.
A child that you don't have to pay college tuition for.
So, yeah.
So, that's why, like, my advice is to, if you want to own a pet, just remember birds are, like, a lifelong commitment.
Alas, I'm already at the tender age of 32.
It is almost time for you to leave our nest and see the world.
But first, you must abide by our tradition.
Before a crow can leave, they must help maintain our nest.
Can you drop down, find an item that you like, and bring it back to me?
At 32, you're dead in internet years.
Okay.
Alright, what the fuck?
That's a treasure chest.
How big is this nest?
Oh, wait.
Okay, I learned the most important thing in this game.
Swoop?
What is swoop?
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Oh, no.
This is hard.
Aiming this is hard.
Oh!
That's a king, right?
That's right.
Now, I shall eat you.
Okay, what am I supposed to grab?
The FPS.
The FPS cro- crokey is here.
Oh, hey.
Oh, this?
Does grandma want this?
Hello, grandma.
I got you the thing you want.
Beautiful!
With every generation, our nest changes and evolves.
Now it's time I give you something from the nest.
Something very special.
What do I get?
I get a glasses!
I get sunglasses.
These glasses have warm colors.
They were worn by me when I was your age.
And my grandma before.
And my grandma's grandma before.
Where's my mom?
Where's my dad?
Am I an orphan?
They're a reminder what sick birds we are.
Our sacred family heirloom.
Treasure it well.
Wait, where's my parents, grandma?
Grandma-ma?
Now, go on.
There's so much to learn.
Talk with the various animals in the village.
They will teach you all the crowy things.
Go on and have fun.
Am I an orphan, grandma?
They got cockatiel?
Like, what was it?
The cuckoo birds?
Did the cuckoo birds kill them?
Is this a Disney film?
All right, let's go.
Oh, no.
Am I...
Am I in a Disney film?
I thought this was a blender icon.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, tab.
Oh, my God.
There's a map.
Thank fucking God.
After playing Wukong, this is like...
This is beautiful to see.
All right.
Space.
Where the fuck are you?
Hola, croaky.
I'm the mystical half-pony, half-hawk.
A pony hawk, if you will.
A rad creature of sick moves.
And it's so cute.
It has a speed of up to 100,000 kilometers per hour.
It's a super fast plane that can fly in a sizable speed.
Speaking of...
Tired of flying slowly?
There's an advanced form of flight called the swoop.
Every time you swoop, you gain a bit of speed.
Hold down the fly button and then press down swoop for a second to then release swoop.
You don't need to release the fly button while swooping.
Repeat this pattern until great distances quickly.
I feel like my parents were supposed to teach me this.
What have...
Is that the button?
Oh, my God.
Is that the crow of 87 using swoops?
Okay.
All right, let's go.
I was like thinking like, what am I?
Oh, shit.
I don't know how to fly because my parents are dead.
I don't think that was it.
I don't think I did it correctly.
That is what happens when my parents are dead.
I don't know how to fly.
Practice how to move through the world much quicker.
You can try restart and try again.
It's tricky, but you'll get the hang of it.
How the fuck?
How the fuck do I do this?
Huh?
Okay.
I don't understand.
Oh, did I do it?
Okay.
Oh, I did it!
I don't need no parents!
Now I have their... now I have their death insurance.
Who even says it was an accident?
Oh, what's this?
It's a walnut.
Hello, I found your walnut.
Hey, you!
I'm gearing up for winter and my kidlets, those little rascals scattered my walnuts.
Can you please use your amazing beak and bring them back to me, pretty please?
What's in it for me?
When you carry an object, you'll see a red aiming pin.
You can't even cross it to the ground.
It shows where the object will fall if you release it.
Oh, wow.
I can't believe it.
After my parents died, like somebody got life insurance for both of them.
I wonder who got who... I wonder what happened.
Well, the police said it was an accident.
It can't be me.
I was a child when it happened.
All right.
Where do I drop it?
Like here?
Is that it?
Here you go.
It was Graham.
All right.
Three.
I was like...
Oh, that rabbit did not like me.
I think I...
He was one of the victims.
Oh, shit!
Whoops, sorry.
Sorry, I got a little...
I got a little excited.
Tookie took them through crime alley.
Much thank.
Remember, not all objects can be picked up.
Some will be too heavy.
You'll get a hang of it, though.
And don't forget to keep checking your map and quest log if you get lost.
I don't get lost.
You know what?
I don't need this map.
I know where I am.
Yeah, see?
Right here.
Hello there.
Hey, are you on flip-flop?
Darling.
What do you mean you don't use flip-flop?
I wasn't an...
I wasn't an iPad kid.
My parents were...
My parents were gone before I could become an iPad kid.
Over 13 million daily active users.
400,000 hours of content.
2 billion minutes watched today.
What do you mean those numbers mean nothing to you?
Those numbers mean everything!
Numbers, numbers, numbers, numbers!
Let's start you off with baby steps.
How about just one quick question?
How about just one quick photo?
One little selfie?
Just try it now!
Numbers go up!
Croaky happy!
Okay, photo mode.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Whoa!
Okay, focus.
Alright.
Ooh, look at me.
I'm a cool-ass bird.
Whoa!
Whoa there!
Slow down!
All the ladies and all the boys!
Whoa!
Can't resist the croaky right there.
Alright.
Nice.
I think...
Whoops!
Okay.
That's a lot of photos.
Alright.
So cool.
I'm so cool.
Can you find the hedgehog?
Where the fuck's the hedgehog?
Hedgehog?
Okay, I can fly forever.
Oh, there he is!
Hello!
Help!
Humans!
Humans invading our forest!
You're a bird, right?
One of them wing fellas, right?
Do you realize you have a special power?
A power no other creatures possess?
Oh my god, what is it?
Am I special?
Am I the chosen one?
Can you guess what it is?
What is it?
Is it the one where it says, poop?
I don't know about you, but I feel like everybody poops.
Do you not poop?
It's not good for you.
Wrong!
It's not pooping?
You can poop down on...
It was!
Wait!
I was right!
You can poop down on unexpecting...
suspecting humans.
Please use this power to scare off the humans.
Oh, and you ran out of poop?
Don't forget to eat some fruit.
Wait, I have a poop.
Poop meter?
Oh, I'm hungry.
How do I eat this?
Oh my god!
Reloading!
Give me a sec, I'm reloading right now.
I'm a very mature crow.
Alright, where's the humans?
Where are they?
Where are the criminals at?
How am I supposed to save the forest if I don't know where they are?
Those fucking campers.
Look at them.
Poop!
Alright.
Oh my god, if only I had my aimbot right now.
Poop!
I don't need aimbot.
I'm a natural talented pro at PS player.
Easy.
Excellent!
This is the kind of chaos I want to see in the world.
Remember, with great poop comes great responsibility.
Now I'll let you onto another secret.
Some foods are special.
Oh my god!
I can upgrade my poop?
It will give you extra power.
But you'll find them later when the time is right.
Okay.
Why didn't grandma teach me any of this?
Oh, they're fine.
Hello.
You seem okay.
You don't seem that mad at me.
FPS pro.
Yosh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, what kind of special powers am I going to have?
Alright.
What's this?
Tools?
Oh, it's a flashlight!
Wait, I want to grab this.
More like balloons and trash.
I can barely play it!
What the fuck?
Wait, oh, these are the...
Wait, is this the special pool?
How are they special?
Wait, how are these special?
It's like glowing.
Okay, wait.
No.
No, get over here.
Get over here!
Get over here and you test it out!
Oh my god!
So fast!
Oh no, I got too excited again.
I got too excited.
What's this?
Oh, there it is!
Oh!
I found Taco Bell!
Alright.
Get over here.
Get over here!
Dodgeball.
Alright, is this food too?
Oh no, no, it's too hot!
It's too hot!
Everything is too hot!
Let me eat!
I need to eat!
Oh, I guess I can throw this.
Phew!
Alright.
Where do I go?
Oh wait, where does this go?
Hello?
This is apparently a quest.
Oh, it's a...
This might sound like a weird flex, but...
I think I can talk to animals.
Oh my god, is that Snow White?
You can't understand me, right bird?
You're hearing me.
I'm not insane, right?
Tell me I'm not insane!
Tell me!
Ah!
You're not insane!
I'm just a really smart bird!
Well, honestly, maybe she is insane.
I'm the smart bird.
Maybe she wants to sing.
Oh shit, sorry.
No!
Sorry!
I need a diaper!
I can't hold it!
Hello?
Oh, sorry.
I was trying to play my clarinet.
Ah!
I'm sorry, Snow White!
Oops!
Sorry!
I didn't mean to!
Whoops!
Sorry!
It's okay!
She's still okay!
That was not what I thought was gonna happen!
Snow White and the seven goats!
I'm so sorry!
I didn't know that was gonna happen!
Snow White!
I don't know what I'm doing!
Wee!
Alright, well, whoops.
Hmm, I bet you think you're smarter than me, huh?
Yes.
Is that it?
Is that all she wanted to say?
I do think I'm smarter than you.
I can talk to humans!
I understand human speech patterns.
Wait, is this Link?
Oh my god!
Hey there.
Hahaha!
Ah!
I overslept!
Thank you for waking me up, bird!
Sorry.
Copyright-free Lonk.
Is this Lonk?
I need to go save the world!
That's Lonk, guys.
World ain't gonna save...
Oh!
I got the cap!
I got the Lonk cap!
Wait, does that mean I can break this?
What if I...
No.
I can't break it.
Alright.
What do I do with this key?
I have, like... I have gasoline and key.
I don't know what to do with it.
Like, does she want anything?
There's no way I actually want anything or she's just there?
Hey, hey, hey!
What am I supposed to do with that?
Alright, let's head over.
Let's exit.
We're not here to be a completionist.
Alright, it's like Mario time.
Smooth landing.
So smooth.
Yeah!
Oh, I got a hat!
Wait, I was supposed to... I was supposed to beat her up.
Snow White's been having it too good for too long.
Alright, nice.
Did you guys hear about that new Snow White movie and then how they... they like, CGI'd all the dwarves and stuff?
Stop!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's a gang!
I'm in... I'm on the wrong turf, guys.
There's crow gangs?
The squawk?
It isn't the new crow in town, eh?
Yeah, yeah.
What?
Who do they think they are?
Ah!
Oh, looks like you got yourself sunglasses, eh?
Yeah, my grandma said that I look really cool in it.
Kaka!
The crow goons!
No!
Now they're mine!
My glasses!
You ain't cool enough for sunglasses.
You're not cool...
Yeah, not cool enough!
So uncool!
My grandma said I was cool!
Ah!
Besides, we need them more than you do.
We have bigger plans than mine, ya dig?
So go back home, kid.
You ain't getting him back.
Kaka!
I believe it.
My glasses!
Am I gonna be cool now?
The crow goons took my glasses!
Oh, what the fuck is this yarn world?
That's random.
Ma, ma!
You're quite the mysterious...
Quite the adventurous bird.
Looks like you unlocked some new hats.
You can always change your appearance by visiting me right here.
Don't be a stranger.
Come by!
Oh, new hat!
New hat!
Weeeeee.
I wanna change my hat.
New hat.
Okay, got the flowers.
I have...
I have long cat.
I like no hat for now.
I have skins too.
I can have scarf colors!
I think the orange Orange fits the best.
Oh my god, I can be naked.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't... I don't like that.
Yeah, let's have the... Oh, I can pitch my crow.
Who was that?
I think it was this one.
Okay, I was like, which one was the original crow?
Alright, it's time for adventure, grandma.
I'm gonna go get my cool sunglasses back, I swear.
Okay, time to terrorize the town now.
Alright.
Oh, okay, there's races?
I don't want race.
I'm just here to find my cool sunglasses back.
That suits you so far.
Wait, you're here too, grandma?
My, my, your glasses are gone.
Your bigger object seems to be stolen as well.
Wait, they took my wallet?
Wait, where did they take my wallet?
I thought you just took my sunglasses.
Seems like a beginning of a grand adventure.
Sound guy, is everything okay so far?
Sorry, sound crow, is everything okay so far?
Let me explain how this goes.
There are animals all over this land who need your help.
You can find them easily by checking your map.
Go talk to them, learn what they need, help them, and earn cro-putation.
Once you hit 100 cro-putation, you can move on to the next area.
Each area lets you earn up to 150... Okay, cro-putation is not, like, repu-crow?
Why didn't they just call it repu-crow?
Repu-crow, like, cro-putation?
What kind of word is that?
Like, repu- if you're gonna add crow to things, just call it repu-crow.
So, you don't need to help all the animals, just enough.
And, uh, open the pause menu to check your progress, your task, and your current cro-putation.
Uh, yes, no, cro-putation sounds so weird.
It just doesn't roll off your tongue very well.
That's all, have fun now.
I don't know.
It's just me, though.
Alright, let's see.
Hello, what do you want from me?
Crowy, crowy, darling.
Look around.
A bunch of stuff is missing.
Those dastardly crows are stealing stuff.
Okay, not all crows.
Not all.
Look, those crows do not represent all crows.
Speaking of missing stuff...
Where is your swag?
What?
You don't have swag?
What kind of cro-
Darling, if you want to be the star of flip-flop, you need swag.
Fly around to find some sha-shiny?
Shiny?
Gold trinkets and bring them here.
If you want to take on those mean crows, you need to have style.
Also, here's a tip.
Swoop into a human to make them drop an item or snatch it off their hands.
In fact, swooping into any object will pick it up if it's not too heavy.
Got it.
Well, go on.
Swagger up.
Alright, time to grab some items.
What is this?
Alright.
Hello, people.
Oh, is that an item for me?
That's right.
Oh, money!
Yoink.
Hahaha.
Yay!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow, guys, it was so sweet.
I got my first super chat, guys.
I got- Uh, dude, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Whoa!
It's okay, I have no HP.
What's he gonna do?
Smack me?
It's okay.
No, I need that.
No, no!
I need that!
I need that super chat!
Please!
Oh!
My parents are dead!
Hahaha.
Hey, putting down the coins.
Boop!
How much do I need?
It doesn't even tell me how much I need.
It just grabs shiny.
Oh, collect!
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, time to rob him.
That's fucking right.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to rob you.
That's right.
Give me a sec.
Zoning on!
That's right.
Wait, you don't even have stuff for me to rob?
Boink!
Mine now.
What's this?
Oh, I can blow leaves.
Wait, how do I slap people with the broom?
Oh, it's gone.
Oops.
Alright, so I lost the...
I lost the... I lost the broom.
It like just... I think it like phased through the floor.
Hey, what's this?
Oh, it's fire!
I'm coming over.
Where is it?
There's like apparently... I remember there was a story of a crow that would actually terror...
Like you were not... You should never... That's fucking right.
Leave.
There's a crow... I don't remember where.
I think it was in Canada.
There's a crow where like...
You cannot go at a certain street because it was like... That was that crow's territory.
That's that crow's... That was that crow's street.
And if you go through that street, he would actually like attack you.
So nobody was like brave enough to go down the street anymore.
And then there was a crow with a knife too.
They were like, beware of the crow with the knife.
Give me more money.
Give me my money!
I'm here to collect my... my loans.
My protection... The protection money.
Remember the protection money?
Where is it?
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Yeah, that's right.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna grab this.
The crow... Yeah.
There's knife crow.
And then there was like a crow that would attack you on a specific street.
Hey,
look.
We had a deal.
You gotta pay me to protect yourself from me.
That was the deal.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Crikey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Crikey isn't real.
Crikey can hurt you.
Crikey with...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't even need four coins.
I got it just because.
Oh, is this a chalice?
Yay!
Why would I use, like, swooping powers when I literally have a flamethrower?
Alright.
This is... This is a glass.
Yay, Shawnee!
Okay, I need to find the bowl and the key now.
I mean, I assume they don't have it.
This is also...
This is also a flamethrower?
That's right.
Get away.
Yeah, that's right.
You wanna hit me?
That's right.
Get away.
Where's the money?
Where's the fucking money?
That's fucking right.
Where is it?
Okay.
Oh, is there a...
Is this a bookstore?
Or a ramen?
I want ramen.
Let me in.
Let Crikey in.
Crikey wants ramen.
Oh, my God.
They don't serve this crows.
This is...
This is discriminate crow.
Hello.
Good day, bird.
That's me.
I am Rupert the Hedgehog.
You might see my twin brother around.
Well, me and my brother are quite different in many ways.
Crow-scrimination.
Sorry.
This is crow-scrimination.
Crikey demands ramen.
What do we share?
A certain thirst for unalterated chaos.
That's it.
Like me.
It would please me deeply to see you blow away some of the humans with briefcases.
How do you want me to do it?
Do you want me to blow them away?
Why, I'll leave that up to you to figure it out.
And oh, while you fly around, poop on your cars along the way.
Humans love it when you decorate their cars.
They do?
Oh, my God.
Is that true?
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'll decorate it.
Oh, you're leaving a little dot in the center.
Boop.
Oh!
Holy shit.
What did I eat?
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck did I eat there?
All right.
Let's blow it down.
Whoa!
Where's the other briefcase man?
Hey, you guys want to have some fun, briefcase man?
You guys want to see a cool trick?
All right.
Wait a minute.
She flipped a car.
Hey, you guys want to...
You want to see a cool trick, man?
Boop.
Whoa.
Where did he go?
And the wife never saw him since.
Oh, my God.
The wife is like, oh, he was supposed to come back like two days ago.
I don't know what happened.
Well, I don't know what happened too.
All right.
Let's see.
We have to go.
Oh, hey.
Is that bread?
Who's...
What the fuck?
My name is...
Is this a developer?
My name is Pit.
Who the fuck are you?
Can I grab you?
What the fuck?
What do I do with Pit?
What do I do with you?
Brad Pit?
Is this Bread Pit?
Is this...
Okay.
That's pretty good.
Not gonna lie.
All right.
Goodbye, Bread Pit.
Oh, hey.
Is this coffee?
Oh, oh.
I have unlimited.
That's fucking right.
Forever?
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, that coffee was fucked up, man.
Sorry.
That coffee...
That coffee did some things.
Oh, a bus.
I've always wanted to poop on a bus.
Okay.
Gotta make sure we got all the square foot area.
Where am I?
Croaky is a little lost.
Oh, Croaky has to go this way.
All right.
Fuck off.
Carl.
Hello, Grandma.
I got the key.
Are you proud of me?
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, I still need to blow away humans.
I got so distracted with the key.
Wait.
Where did I...
Where did I put the...
Where did I put the leaf blower?
Hello?
My babies.
They're gone.
Disappeared.
Removed.
Unexisted.
That's great.
That's great, ma'am.
Now you don't have to pay for more college tuitions.
You're free now.
Bro, I know what you are.
You can just get kids in like two months.
Probably just ran away like the little rascals they are.
Couldn't have gone far.
They must be somewhere around.
Will you bring them back to me?
All of them?
Why would you want all of them?
Wouldn't one be the best?
I am mother.
I need my babies.
In like one to two months, you'll have more babies.
Liz?
I know what you are.
More like weeks.
That's true.
Oh, you're right.
She hungry.
You're right.
That's why she wants more.
She...
Oh, wait.
What kind of...
What kind of ammo did I got now?
Oh, it's like a speed boost.
Wee!
Wee-oo!
Oh!
It's a fucking speed boost.
All right.
I need to find...
What happened to my leaf blower though?
Oh, so there's one of the babies.
All right.
Get over here.
Where did I find bread pit?
Was bread pit over here?
Where the fuck did I found bread pit?
Bro, bread pit is so old now.
Here we go.
All right.
Oh, it's over here.
No.
That's the key.
Wait.
There was more than one key?
Where the fuck did I found...
Where's the leaf blower?
Far left?
Okay.
It should be here around here.
I beat up...
I beat up one guy somewhere here.
Wait.
I hear one of the hammies or the squirrels.
All right.
Get over here.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
It was reflex.
All right.
nmeros.
Feed your momma.
Feed the weakest to the mom.
That's why they eat the kids, by the way.
It's cause they're like...
They need the extra nutrients.
Um, and it's either they're...
as like the weakest out of all the babies so they're like, well, obviously we need to get rid of one of you, Because like there's no point in raising you to adulthood.
So they eat the child.
Yeah, only the strongest survive.
Or boredom.
Sometimes they're just bored.
They're like, ooh.
Protein.
Yeah, so you better not be a weak squirrel.
This is awesome.
God damn it.
Where did I put my leaf blower?
Where did I park that thing?
Guys, do you guys remember which parking lot?
Guys, where did I park my leaf blower?
Was it like, was it P3?
Oh, it's here, it's here.
I found it.
Alright, it was P4.
Guys, I told you to remember the parking lot number.
You think I was gonna remember that?
Alright, we need to find another briefcase guy.
Please never go near... dude, where's my leaf blower?
Dude, where's my car?
Wait, who has, who has the suitcase?
Hello?
Oh, fuck, okay.
Boom!
Alright, did the thing.
I still need a ball.
And I need to find one more squirrel kid.
Alright, I'm gonna park it here now.
Guys, remember where the leaf blower was parked, guys?
Fuck, where is he?
Where is he?
There's too many.
There are way too many animals.
There's way too many animals here.
Okay, it should be like...
Okay, maybe I do need the map.
Where is he?
Wait, is that a bull?
That must be a bull, right?
Oh my god, you think a door can stop me?
That's fucking right.
You ain't got the dog bull.
No dog bull for you.
Okay, there you go.
I got the swag.
I got the swag, Ms. Peacock!
I did it!
Oh, okay, she doesn't want to talk to me.
That's fine.
I didn't want to talk to you either.
On the conbini?
Is that the conbini?
No.
Oh, that is!
That is!
No, that's the brother!
Help!
Those humans have taken over my home!
My beautiful park!
How dare they!
They think...
That land was owned by his great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great grand hog.
How dare they!
I bet they don't even have a permit.
It appears they're having some kind of devilish ritual.
Please, please do what is your power to ruin it!
Alright, don't worry, I got you.
Let me grab...
Let me grab this coffee real quick.
I...
Don't worry.
Oh shit!
Nothing can stop me now.
The children aren't even safe.
Oh, I gotta pop balloons.
That's right.
Fuck you, kids.
You don't deserve happiness.
If I'm not happy, you're not happy.
Leave!
Oh, destroy the radio?
And also, fuck music too!
No more music!
How do I destroy music?
That's right!
What's this?
Oh, Shiny!
Wait, how do I... Oh, I didn't pop all the balloons.
Give me a sec.
Sorry, I almost forgot to pop all the balloons.
Don't you dare run away.
Alright.
Oh, I know.
That's fucking right.
Music is now banned!
Boom!
Oh, you wonderful fiend.
You've done it!
Thank you so much!
Another small step towards complete animal domination.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Alright, I did my job.
Traumatize the child.
Abandon these parts.
This is croaky territory.
Alright.
I am completing the circle.
If I got bullied by the other crows...
I'm...
I just need to find somebody smaller than me.
And continue the cycle.
Hey!
Croaky!
How's it going?
Play with me.
You can go with me!
Call me!
Let me!
Let me the lemur!
You're...
Yes, I am.
You like, like, one smart bird.
Eh?
You!
Ohh!
Croaky doing quests.
Let's pop- Oh, Shiny.
Hahaha!
Mirka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
But you're smart enough to use tools, aren't you?
Yeah!
I'm pretty smart.
My crow goons say I'm smart before they take my lunch money and my sunglasses.
So?
Some objects you pick up have a special use.
How about we practice your usability?
Me and the boys were talking.
These humans getting mad wild in our turf.
You know what I'm saying?
Guess it's time to remind them who runs this place.
Grab one of the spray cans and tag a bunch of red mailboxes.
Just like the one right here.
Thou teach them!
I'm gonna start tagging.
Oh my god.
Thou teach them!
I'm gonna tag the place.
It's all about personal branding, you dig?
Not graffiti.
Oh no!
Croaky!
You're not doing graffiti!
Oh god.
Croaky is so... I'm so bad.
Oh my god.
I'm so bad, guys.
That's right.
Graffiti hours.
It's time for crime.
Alright, we gotta find some more mailboxes.
Oh, there's more here.
Oh my god.
Imagine how much money the government has to spend to clean my graffiti.
Oh, what a punk.
This is croaky turf now.
Alright.
I got my... I got my tags in.
I'm the next Banksy.
Croaky.
Okay.
Let's see.
Croaky, croaky, my bird!
You have done us a solid!
Now these pesky humans won't forget we own this place.
Good work!
Ayyyy!
Alright, nice.
Alright, uh...
Where do I have to go?
Where the fuck is that other hedgehog?
Is it here?
It should be here.
No, that's the mom.
I'm still like...
Oh, I already...
Oh, because I finished it!
So, like, I don't have to...
I don't have to, like, talk to him again.
That's why.
What if I spring paint a human?
You stupid humans don't know what hits them.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Consume that toxic fume.
You're not wearing a mask.
Oh, you're in...
Your poor lungs.
Ooh.
You're getting pink fumes now.
That's right.
You're gonna get something very bad.
Alright.
Witness me.
Oh, hey, there's another child.
Alright, get over here.
What if I just drop you from high?
You okay there, buddy?
Are you okay?
What about the child?
Grookey, no!
He's gonna get eaten anyway!
It doesn't matter!
Ow!
Alright, here you go.
Here's your kids.
My babies are all home!
Thank you, bird.
Come here!
Alright,
I did it.
Yeah, I'm just tenderizing it for the mom.
Making sure the meat is nice and tender for her.
One of my old friends, back in middle school, she used to own hamsters.
And then the hamster she got, because she bought the hamster online, and then she didn't know it was pregnant.
So one day, there was just suddenly babies.
But then the mom started eating the babies.
And the mom ate the one...
Before she could eat the baby, the mom ate its legs.
And I was like, what the fuck?
That was the first time I found out.
I basically got trauma in middle school.
And found out that hamsters eat their kids.
Because of my friend.
She had more trauma because she had to watch it happen.
But yeah, I was like, oh my god, the mom ate the foot?
And she was like, yeah, it ate the foot.
And I was like, what the fuck?
I was like...
And that's how I learned about animal cannibalism.
I was like, but poor me, I had to hear the story.
I was like, my friend had to watch it happen.
But poor me, I had to listen to that story.
I had to go through the story.
Squee!
There's a big fat cat down below.
And he wants to eat us.
I mean, you are looking juicy.
Help, croaky, help!
I met this fat cat.
I would love some fish as well.
Drop some fish near him and he'll be sure to follow.
Oh my god, that looks like some juicy little rats there.
Hello, little rats.
There should be a leaky pipe on one of the buildings near us.
Lead the cat to get splashed and he'll be sure to scram.
Save us!
Squee!
I mean, look at it.
They're like little...
They're like little nerds.
You know?
They're like M&Ms.
Alright, where the fuck is the cat?
Alright, there's the cat.
Alright, cat, follow me.
Cat!
Cat, come on!
I have fish!
Alright.
Where's the pipe?
There's apparently a leaky pipe somewhere.
Alright.
There you go.
Where is it?
Meow.
So there's a leaky pipe somewhere.
Where the fuck is the leaky pipe?
Hello?
They all look the same.
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Alright, get over here, cat.
Get over here.
Why can't you talk to me?
Are like...
Do predators not like...
Cannot...
Do predator and prey have like different...
Well, to be fair, I'm a predator too.
But like...
I guess like I'm not...
Well, I could technically be a predator.
But like...
Is this like Zootopia?
Are we like discriminating against the predator...
Predator animals?
Are they like too stupid to understand us?
I mean, look at him.
He looks too stupid.
Alright, look at this.
Yeah, I know.
He's definitely stupid.
He's...
You know...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I need to grab...
Oh, sorry.
I got too...
Oh, I got so excited.
I'm so excited right now.
Alright.
I need to grab more fish.
No, I need to grab more fish!
There you go.
Alright, get over here.
You're gonna get wet now.
Look at this stupid cat.
Alright, we did it.
Alright, mice.
I did it.
Ha!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Many asked me to voice his inner thoughts for him.
Squee!
You lured the ugly cat away!
Thank you, Crowy.
Thank you!
Kaka!
Another job well done for Crowkey.
Alright.
Whoops.
Sorry, I got really excited when I got the job well done.
Hello!
Hello, Ponyhawk!
Hola, Crow!
Are you practicing your swoops to move faster like I showed you?
I know it feels hard, but think how good it would be if you want to get a hang of it.
Anyway, I think it's time to...
No, not races!
I'm so bad!
This is like the Spyro PTSD right now.
I hated the Spyro races.
Um...
It'll activate a special race mode.
Just land on it and squawk to activate.
Then fly all the checkpoints that appear as fast as you can.
Find all the races in the world and complete them for much, much fun.
Every race you complete will increase your computation.
If you're struggling or want an extra challenge, you can always change the race difficulty.
Just pause the game and go to settings...
Wait, really?
Alright.
No, wait.
Give me...
Wait.
Nobody likes races, guys!
Nobody likes it anyway.
Oh my god, I'm going...
Guys, I did hard difficulty, by the way.
Yay!
Wait, I'll...
I guess, like, can I just walk out?
Walk?
If it's easy?
Like...
Yay...
I'm so good!
Yay!
It'll be fine!
We don't even need to fly!
Like, literally, like, 60 seconds?
There's something wrong with this bird.
Oh my god.
This is so easy.
Wait, no!
I have to fly!
Okay, now back to...
Back to the leisurely walk.
Wait, am I going to get second place?
Oh my god!
Guys, I got second!
Yippee!
This bird has issues.
Alright, let's get at least first.
Oh my god!
I'm so good, guys!
I'm so good at races!
You see?
This is the easiest race of my life.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm on the hardest difficulty when it comes to racing.
By the way.
Wait, it doesn't even matter.
I just need to complete it.
It doesn't even matter.
As long as I complete it, I get the same amount of points.
I'm so good.
Alright, I did it.
I did it, grandma!
Oh shit, sorry.
Gamer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Dookie, I love your vibe.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Wait, I'm missing?
Oh, it's the races.
There's like a hundred million of them.
Oh!
I didn't want that samurai hat anyway.
I didn't even want that.
I don't want to be a samurai.
I'm a fucking bird.
Whoa!
Wait up, squib!
So, you're that new crow everyone's talking about.
They're talking about me?
Me?
I'm getting popular?
I'm all about popular.
Thought you'd be bigger.
Hey!
I'm a short crow.
I'm a short king.
Anyway, you must think you're like the protagonist of this adventure, huh?
Yeah.
Well, let me introduce myself.
I am Maggie the magpie.
The smartest of all birds.
Everyone knows magpies are smart.
What?
That is not true!
That cannot be true!
Where's your sunglasses?
I don't have sunglasses right now.
I left it at home.
Thus henceforth, let it be known this is just magpie things.
And you?
You're just an...
What?
So, watch your back crow.
I'll beat you every step.
Through every step of the way.
Whack, Whack-a-whack.
Whack-a-whack-a-whack.
Yes, that's right.
Real birds.
Whack.
Only...
I'm not a loser!
My grandma says I'm cool...
I'm not a loser, right, crocoons?
I'm not a loser.
What does this hat look like?
What the fuck?
Okay, I don't think I like that.
No, you don't have your sunglasses.
I don't need... do you see that cute backpack I have?
I don't need sunglasses.
Look at this cute backpack.
I'm on an adventure.
Wait, the masks have stats?
Wait, did they really?
I thought they were just customization.
Okay, cute little enable with the spirit improves your...
No, it doesn't.
What the fuck?
Improves your cunning?
I don't need improvement.
I'm already smart.
Alright, nice.
We're going to ancient Egypt.
Backpack oven.
Is this why they took my lunch money?
The humans used to worship us.
Alright, we're back.
We somehow flew to Egypt, guys.
But lately, they've become very lazy.
What's the last time anyone gave your chin a scritch?
What was the last time someone moved a little string around to amuse you?
The Pharaoh's headdress is a symbol of power around here.
Bring me the Pharaoh's headdress.
Whoever brings me the Pharaoh's headdress will be handsomely rewarded.
It is time to restore power to cats.
I don't think they know.
They'll never know that I'm not actually a cat.
Guys, I can't believe...
Guys, did you guys know Egypt is like right next to Japan?
Alright, let's go.
I bet you guys didn't know that.
Holy shit, is that a shiny?
Really?
Yeah, it's right.
Video games don't lie to you.
Of course.
If the video game that says that Japan is just next to Egypt, then I trust it.
It has a crow.
I'm meant to be a strong, magnificent idol.
The lady here, she does not understand the importance of protein.
She feeds me melon and now I'm soft round.
Bring me fish from the market.
In return, you'll gaze upon my glistening muscles.
Oh yeah, don't feed... don't make your cat vegan.
They can actually get sick, by the way.
Alright.
Like, cats are not meant to be vegan.
Alright, let's grab that fish.
Ah, I can't grab it.
They're so bouncy.
Alright, cat.
Here's a fish.
Finally.
Finally, I have returned to my true form.
Look upon my enormous muscles.
Damn.
Do you want to touch them?
You may.
Be not afraid.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
Pew!
Not the headdress.
Okay, we can't do that yet.
Alright.
Where does the pharaoh live?
Does Egypt still have pharaohs?
No, right?
Oh my god.
Being croaky actually made me dumber.
I'm like, no, of course not.
Pharaohs don't exist anymore.
What am I saying?
No, but if the game says that pharaohs exist, then it should be true.
Because this game... this game wouldn't lie to me.
This game wouldn't lie to me, chat.
My friend, you look like you appreciate the finer things.
In life, no.
Help me with my little business and you'll have everything you could ever dream of.
During the day, I sell jewels to discerning buyers.
And at night, I steal them back.
She's a cat burglar.
What do you say?
Wanna be pals?
Only if I get like a 50-50 cut.
We can be business partners after that.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where did I leave my jewel?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Yoink.
There's five?
Damn.
There's five jewels.
Alright, let's...
Wouldn't it be easier to just 3D print some jewels?
Nice.
Alright.
Where else?
Where are the other jewels?
I don't wanna do any of the races, not gonna lie.
The races sound like hell.
The races sound like they suck.
It just gives me a spiral piece.
I'm a bit of a PTSD because I fucking hated the races there.
But I needed to do them to unlock areas.
Somebody had the nerve to put my goats in a pen.
Break them free and lead them into the market.
Take this funny looking tool thing.
The goats like the noises it makes.
Oh!
I'm like a snake charmer but for goats.
What can I not do?
I have the... I'm like that guy with a million jobs.
Oh shit, sorry.
Whoops.
No, I can't grab it!
Get over here, goats!
Get over here!
That's looking right!
Storm the gates!
That's right!
Oh!
No, my... No!
My beautiful musical instrument!
Alright.
Can't get me.
That's right!
Wait, where is the cat?
This way.
Oh, the market.
Get over here!
Follow the leader!
Drown!
Humans!
Freedom!
You shall not be chained by the pesky meatbags!
That's right!
Storm the markets!
Alright, sorry.
My job's done.
Yay!
Alright.
What else do I have to do?
Okay, we gotta find the jewelry.
Where is some more jewelry?
Wait, what's this?
It's a melon.
Do I get to go big?
Like the other cat?
Oh, no.
It's just regular food.
Oh, there's another cat!
Hello, other cat!
Hey!
It'd be a shame if the market was covered in weird frogs.
What a shame, indeed.
Yeah, it'd be a shame if someone with wings grabbed a frog and put it in a cloud.
Oh my god.
Am I a bad crow?
Am I getting influ- Am I in like, the bad parts of town?
This is what my grandma said.
It only takes one bad turn.
Who would do such a thing?
Oh, but remember the frogs only come out at night.
Wait, how does it turn nighttime?
How do I make it nighttime then?
With shit on you.
That's fucking right.
That's right, learn your lesson.
We could have done this the nice way, but you had to bring- You have to bring in the big guns there.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's a race.
Okay, let's see.
Put frogs- Frogs only- How do I make it nighttime?
I don't know how to make it nighttime.
I don't control the fucking weather.
Do not eat the colorful fruit.
It will give you the most horrible, shameful, stinky poops.
Uh oh, stinky.
Poops are so cursed, even a single web will send someone into delirium.
I've seen even the most fearsome warriors run for the hills.
Seriously, for everyone's safety, do not eat those.
I'm gonna eat it.
Oh, no!
No!
I'm not happy now.
I'm gonna eat it now.
Yummy.
Okay, I did the- There you go.
Wait, that's it?
That's fucking it?
It doesn't even do anything special.
It's just my regular, regular time.
How do I turn it into night?
I still don't know how to turn it into night.
Okay, that's the cat that wants me to steal the pharaohs.
Oh, there's the magpie.
There's the bitch.
Alright, hello.
You're too late, croaky.
I already hit the magical lantern past those tornadoes.
What is the mag- Oh, it turns into night!
Guess you'll just never know.
Squeak!
Oh, the yellow- Oh, the fruits on the trees?
Oh!
Oops, sorry.
Oh, these fruits!
Okay, so this?
Ah!
Let the crow eat!
Alright, I did it.
What does it do?
Oh!
I made that.
Okay, apparently we gotta find the...
Oh!
Oh, it makes me fly higher!
Oh no, it sends you back in the beginning.
Never mind.
That's a strong tornado.
But then, like, but they always say, if you go in the middle of the tornado, you'll be safe.
Alright.
Woo!
Don't worry, I'm safe.
Is that it?
Oh, I don't have a key?
Hello?
I trapped the sun in this lantern to teach the humans a lesson.
But they don't even care!
Here, you can have it.
Be careful not to drop it too low on the ground, or else...
What's gonna happen?
Oh!
If I drop it, it turns into night.
I see.
Oh, it has to be like...
Oh!
Whoops, goodbye.
Whee!
Fast travel.
Yay!
Okay.
If it's not the ground, then the frogs come out.
Where the fuck are the frogs?
The fucking goats.
Where are the frogs at?
Where do they go?
Oh, there they are!
Hello, little froggies.
We're gonna start a plague.
Where's the clouds, though?
What do clouds look like?
Wait, but...
I don't know what clouds look like.
Does the clouds have to be...
Oh no, they disappear!
No!
Where the fuck do clouds look like?
I've never seen a cloud before.
Look, I'm like one years old, apparently.
On the sky to the left?
Oh, there it is!
No!
My frog!
I thought that was clouds!
No!
My frog!
But they look like clouds!
Where the fuck are clouds?
He died for nothing.
He's a fucking frog.
Frogs can swim.
They play at the market?
Oh, there they are!
I see it!
Oh my god, that's what clouds are.
My first time seeing a cloud.
I am traveling around the world.
Alright.
There you go.
There's one frog.
I need five?
Wait, when did I put four?
Oh wait, no.
Okay.
I need to put four.
Alright.
One frog.
Time to start a plague.
Hey!
This is what no god would have wanted.
Alright.
Get over here.
God wanted this.
Alright.
Two!
Or three!
And then we need...
We need one more.
Alright.
You're the chosen one.
Ah!
Gah!
Wait, where the fuck is the last cloud?
One.
Two.
Three.
Oh, there it is!
I did it!
I started a plague!
Yay!
Billions are gonna die now!
Holy shit!
Holy...
That's a lot of frogs.
Oh, that's a lot.
Did I overdo it?
Nah.
Alright, let's see.
Still need to find, like, three more diamonds somewhere.
Wait.
The Pharaoh must live here.
Oh!
Ow.
I got tree blocked.
This is what god wanted.
Meow.
Oh, you know, there's some good stuff in that cave.
That temple.
There is?
Look at this place and tell me there isn't loads of shiny trinkets inside.
But there's some kind of puzzle on the door.
Can you figure it out, Crogi?
I mean, I already have.
Obviously, because I am so smart.
But...
What?
I will wait for you to figure it out.
So you can learn too and be as smart as me one day.
Shiny?
I mean...
Alright, let's...
I think we need the lantern, right?
Where do I put the lantern?
Alright, we gotta grab the lantern.
Where do I put it?
Where do I put my insurance?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Get over here.
Oh, I hear it.
I hear the door close.
Down, up.
Alright.
I need to put it down.
All the way down.
Down!
Yay!
Oh my god!
I can't fly higher!
Wait!
But it's night time!
I can't fly higher!
Ow!
I can't!
I don't know how to fly high!
Oh, I have to time it?
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, that's fucked!
Get down!
Woah, woah, woah!
I did it!
Nice!
Oh, look at all these treasures!
You poor soul.
So much Shiny!
There's no treasure here.
All your finest skeletons of fools like me got lured into the tomb.
And soon you'll be one of us.
There's no way out.
But... but there's Shiny!
There is no escape from the tomb.
But this is Shiny.
There's no way.
Oh my god, I'm fucking strong as hell.
Maybe I have to put this?
Oh, okay.
That skeleton was just stupid.
Alright.
And then another chest.
And then...
Oh, no!
Alright.
Damn, how strong am I?
What am I?
This is not... woah!
Yum.
Alright, what else?
What else can I use?
Can I use, like, skeleton heads?
What else can I pick up?
Oh my god.
Can I pick you up?
No, what?
I feel like...
Maybe if I, like, poop on it?
If I poop enough, do you think I can open it?
No, okay.
My poop doesn't add weight to it.
My poop...
Bananas!
Guys, I can't pick up bananas, guys.
It won't let me.
I can only eat.
I can only consume.
Guys, let me out!
I don't understand.
What can I pick up?
The pots?
Oh, I can pick up pots!
Okay, I figured it out.
Alright.
No!
Stay on it!
Stay on the thing!
No!
Okay, nice.
And then...
Yay!
Can I open it?
What?
No, stay on top!
Is it the poop?
There we go.
And then...
Yay!
Tornado!
What does tornado do?
Does it throw me out?
I did it!
Unlock the pyramids!
I still need like...
The diamonds.
But I don't know where the diamonds are.
I'm like missing like two more diamonds.
Why are they so scared of me?
What did I do?
There's no way they know I caused the plague.
Do you think they know I caused the plague?
No.
That's impossible.
Those humans aren't smart enough to know.
Alright.
Yay!
Where the fuck is the pharaoh?
Okay, we need...
Ow!
Okay, we need like two more diamonds.
Where could the last two diamonds be?
They hide them so well.
I don't understand.
It's like they don't want me to steal it.
But why wouldn't they?
I'm a crow.
That's what crows do.
You leave the diamonds out...
so then the crows can steal the diamonds.
Alright, one more.
One more.
Just crow things.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I think the owner found the big cat.
No!
I want the shiny thing!
Okay, nice.
Yeah!
Oh, wrong way.
I flew past it.
The shiny thing...
obscured my vision.
Yay!
Okay, I'll knock over the pharaoh's headdress for real quick.
And then he lives here.
Hello, pharaoh.
That's right.
You think...
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there you are.
Boop.
Oh, you think those guards can stop me?
That's fucking right.
You can't stop me.
You can't stop me!
Wait, give me a sec.
I missed.
Oh, please!
It's shiny!
Please stop stopping me!
Yeah, you can't stop.
No!
It's so...
They're playing Crow Baseball!
Don't make me use this!
There's so many guards!
It's okay, I'm reloading.
Reloading!
Oh, shit!
Okay, it got reloaded.
Eventually, it'll hit.
Yeah, that's right.
Slip.
Slip and slap.
No, come on!
No!
I will brute force this!
I guess I'll grab the yellow fruit.
Fine.
I'll grab the yellow fruit.
I just feel a little embarrassed eating one of those, you know?
Everybody starts staring at me.
Everybody just stares at me.
I feel so embarrassed.
No!
Let me at it!
That's right, I'll surround it.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
I was so stealthy.
I did it.
The stealthiest crow out there.
Here's your fucking headdress.
Yes!
Look who's wearing the big guy hat now!
Meow!
Someone!
Now!
Bird!
Carry me to the palace!
Oh, shit!
Okay, now he's the king, I guess.
Alright, get over here.
It'll be a shame if I just go.
You!
What are you made of?
Alright, here I go.
Wew!
Feral delivery!
Meow!
Oh my god!
I think I did a good thing today.
And now, Egypt is owned by cats.
As God intended.
Alright, time to land.
I did it!
Yay!
The perfect palace.
Wait, what's that?
Wait, is that skin?
Wait!
No!
Now I actually do have to do the races!
It's a new skin!
I want to know what the new skins are!
God damn it.
I have to do the hardest race of my life.
Oh, man.
I have to do the hardest race I've ever done in my life.
The races that are at ultra hard difficulty.
Alright, nice.
I think dad found out about the cats.
I think dad was not happy about the cat situation.
What the, like...
What the fuck are these races?
Like, what?
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Crow FPS gamer here.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I don't like that.
This is... oh my god.
Why did they have to make the races...
Why?!
No!
No, I ran out of fucking ammo!
Reloading.
I need to reload!
Okay, there we go.
This thing sucks.
Race abandoned?!
How?!
How did I miss?!
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got this.
I missed one?!
I just want to know what that was!
Okay, here we go.
No, no, no, no.
No!
Reloading!
Okay, nice.
Boop.
Alright.
And then...
Boop.
I won't make it to the top!
Oh my god, how did this game get harder?
No, I ran out!
I ran out of ammo!
Oh my god, okay.
Thank god, this is so dumb.
Oh my god, I'm running out of ammo too.
No!
Get out of these broads!
Please!
Leave me alone!
No!
Oh, I just made it.
I literally just made it.
I literally just made it to the end.
I already got the...
I already hit it.
I already did this quest.
You're fucking too slow.
No, you're too slow.
Alright.
This is the last time I'm ever doing the race.
I just need 150.
Please tell me I don't have to poop again, please.
No!
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
Croaky, you can do this, Croaky.
Remember what your grandmama taught you, Croaky.
Come on.
Not like that.
Not like that, Croaky.
Remember the other lessons that your grandmama taught you.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I got it.
I did it.
Oh my god, five more.
Two more races to go.
Dad, please!
I know this is embarrassing!
What the fuck?
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
This is not a race!
Okay.
We can do it.
This is fine.
We're just walking.
Can't be that bad.
What kind of race is this?
Easy.
Okay.
One more.
One more to go.
Please, no more.
Please, just race.
No, no.
I hope to...
Oh, the tornadoes are gone.
Thank god.
Okay, never mind.
Alright.
The last race.
Okay, this is actually a lot...
Okay, never mind.
Maybe not.
I just realized the tornadoes are very dangerous.
It might not be as easier as I thought.
Oh.
Oh, no!
No!
Oh, I hit the thing.
I just went a lot.
Stupid tornadoes.
Wait.
No!
It's not fair!
This race isn't fair!
This flight is set to you'll be safe.
This is it.
Croaky was never meant to fly.
No!
The moment I flew, I knew it.
I knew Croaky was never meant to fly.
Okay, okay, this time.
This time it'll work, guys.
Alright.
Croaky's got this.
Fuck off!
Okay, there we go.
If I don't fly, they can't hurt me.
If I don't...
I'm just scouting ahead.
Ahhh!
Wait, can I just do it at night?
Oh my god, wait.
In night time, there's no tornadoes.
Okay, you're right.
No!
I'll eventually be able to get there.
Oh my god.
You're right.
Tornadoes are...
Tornadoes need to sleep.
So at night time, they don't show up.
That's the tornado lore.
Did you guys know that even tornadoes need their nap time?
Alright.
There we go.
We should be fine.
Tornado lore.
Yeah.
They're off the clock at like 8pm.
Their shift starts at like 8am to 8pm every day.
So you just gotta find the right tornado hours.
So like, if the...
So like, tornadoes don't exist after 8pm.
They're like salarymen.
Oh my god.
Woo!
I did it, guys.
I figured it out.
Alright.
Nice.
Yay!
Yeah!
We did it.
We completed everything.
Wow, even tornadoes have union...
have unions.
Alright, what did I unlock?
Where's my nest?
Boop.
So what did I unlock?
Oh my god!
I can be a chicken!
Alright.
I wanna see what it looks like.
What does a chicken look like?
How many skins are there?
Oh, I don't like chicken croquis.
No, we gotta get back to croquis.
Guys, the skins lie.
Alright.
No, no return to chicken.
Oh, we're gonna be camping?
How many levels are there?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, Wow, guys!
There's only one level left.
Wow!
Can't believe it!
This is such a fast game!
This is the last level, everybody!
Wow!
Alright.
What the fuck?
Freeze?
Hello, crow.
We had a busy hiking season.
Lots of campers.
Not all of them very thoughtful, you know.
Some left their fires still burning around the forest.
So irresponsible.
Say, would you be a grand bird and help us put them up?
Just splash them with some water or some other bodily fluids if you can catch my drift.
Thanks, crow.
Remember, only you can prevent forest fires.
How did it get so big?
Wait, did I do it?
I guess I did because it stopped making noises.
How did...
Are they people?
Animals?
Or furries?
I can't tell!
What kind of abominations are they?
If I put fire on it and then put it out with my...
Oh no.
Not the fast poop.
Are they animals?
Hello there, little crow.
Look at that mess.
Our camp is in shambles.
Bunch of mean crows showed up and stole stuff.
Can you believe it?
I heard they've been stealing things to build their own secluded city.
Could it be?
Anyway, maybe you can help us restore our camp.
I saw them drop a few fuel cans at the abandoned gas station just south of here.
But be careful, I heard wicked noises from that direction.
Okay, I need to get like fuel for the camp.
Ooh, spooky.
First self.
Surf is up.
Is self down?
Self is down, right?
Oh, there's like dinosaur bones.
Hey, crow!
You know what's really trending right now?
What?
Wrong!
Dinosaurs!
Please, crow.
Please put this dinosaur skeleton together.
My fans, my audience on flip-flap, they crave dinosaurs.
Do it for the flap!
Please!
Okay.
What do I do?
Do I just give you the bone?
Oh!
Oh, I have to assemble it for you!
Oh my gosh, she is an influencer.
I bet she wants it for free too.
Fucking influencers?
Couldn't be me.
I'm just a regular crow.
Wouldn't be influencing anything.
Got your leg.
Bird leg.
Oh!
I don't put this.
Oh, that's how I put it.
No for exposure.
Yeah, she seems like an exposure bird.
And not the good kind of exposure.
I'm gonna get paid for exposure, man.
Oh!
Did I?
No!
I didn't put a fire out!
Okay, I needed the normal poops.
Not the fast one.
We are not going fast today.
Where's the skull?
I'm just missing the skull.
Where the fuck did they put it?
Hello?
Wait, is this danger?
Oh, this is danger cloud.
Oh, there it is.
Hello!
Here's the skull.
Ah!
Yay!
Oh my god!
The dinosaur slaps!
I pushed it off.
It's all over the bird net.
We're gonna be so viral.
Thank you again, crow!
Yeah?
Do I get paid?
Oh, I got 15 exposure bucks.
Thank you so much.
I can feed my family now.
Oh my god.
Guys, I got my 15 exposure bucks.
Guys, it's over.
It's so over for all of you.
Oh, hey.
Who's...
Did they lose the children again?
Oh my god.
She lost her kids again?
Alright, let's find the mom.
Where the fuck is the mom?
Hello?
Croaky, croaky, help!
My brother has gone missing!
He went on about some spooky shadows.
And went deep into the forest.
Cucumber and Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please follow his tracks and find him.
Oh, and be careful.
Maybe there's something that can help.
Alright.
Where the fuck is the mom?
I gotta stop that forest fire.
Can't have any fires coming out.
I don't know where the mom's at.
Oh, hey.
Alright, I'm gonna put you here.
This creature, they come from the dark.
But they fear the light.
I must press onwards.
If I don't catch them long enough, they will surely disappear.
Alright.
How bad can they be?
I'm a fucking crow.
Is it these guys?
What are they gonna do, slap me?
Oh.
Okay, they make it sound like he's gonna fucking kill me.
The lamps, of course, I can lure them in and they will be toast.
But like, they are just existing.
They're not even doing anything dangerous.
It's not just figures.
The objects, too.
They're possessed by the same darkness.
Are the shadows coming from my nightmares?
Or are the... wait, is this...
Is this Alan Wake?
Yeah, I was gonna say!
Wait a minute, is this Alan Wake?
It's Crow Key Wake.
Yeah, that's right.
Get over here.
Oh, okay.
He did get over here.
What do I do?
Whoa!
Oh my god, it is Alan Wake!
Alright, guys.
It's Crow Key Wake.
Oh!
I need to get the generator!
Cure them!
They're trying to lock him in!
But there has to be a way to open the gate!
I must be smart!
I don't need no flashlight!
Okay, we need to get the...
How the fuck do I press this button?
Oh!
Okay, that's how.
Okay, yellow!
And then green!
What is it gonna do?
Fucking kill me?
It's a fucking garbage bag.
There you go.
Yay!
Nobody is smarter than a crow.
How long has it been since I've seen sunlight?
Days?
Years?
The time passes strangely here.
Oh, I see a house!
A place of refuge!
Over there!
Oh shit, forest fire!
Help!
Oh, is that the brother?
Oh, a crow!
My brother must have sent you!
Oh my god!
Hedge wake!
Please, I'm stranded, surrounded!
I cannot make my escape!
Defeat the shadow creatures below by all means possible!
Don't worry, I know what to do!
Don't worry!
Hedge wake!
I know what to do!
Ow!
I'll just stand right here!
I did it!
By doing nothing at all!
My goodness!
You did it!
You saved us, Croaky!
You magnificent bird!
Phew!
You should be safe from now on.
Looks like some of the magical fog lifted too.
You should be able to get around more easily.
Gosh!
I will spread the stories of your brave battles far and wide!
Mock my words!
It's that easy!
The fog gun?
Oh, I can go through it now!
Oh, hey!
There's more flashlight!
Yeehaw!
Howdy, crow!
Ah, I'm Steven!
Hey, Steven!
The ultimate shadow of the seven deaths of nightmares and misery!
And your name is Steven?
Damn!
To be fair, Steven's...
All Stevens are bad!
Never trust a Steven!
You know, when possessing innocent campers, I thought to myself, there has to be more to life than this.
So I decided to pack my bags and go traveling.
I've climbed the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
I ate a pickle heron in Helsinki.
I drove cross-country visiting all the United States.
I'm not the young shadow I used to be no more.
So I came back home to settle down.
Be with my family and friends.
You know how I do.
Built me this here little house for myself.
But alas, it got covered by other shadows.
Would you be a dear and use this flashy light of yours to clean up all the other darkness?
So you want me to commit murder?
Just don't point it at me because, you know, what happens?
Anyway, I appreciate your help in this matter.
Damn!
He hates his own kind.
Wait.
You don't die.
Whoops.
Oops.
You're fine.
I can't believe it!
He hates his own shadow kind!
He wants to be the last remaining shadow!
It just hurts a little bit.
Well, darn.
You've done me a great solid, Crow!
What if that was his family and he was like, I can't have my mother-in-law live with me again.
Oh, man.
My mother-in-law, she like disappeared.
Same with like my father-in-law.
What a shame.
Sorry, sweetie.
Don't know what happened to them.
I guess they just left.
They did visit us, but they just left today.
You just missed them.
I'll be sure to let everyone know what's the great partner you are.
Don't be a stranger.
Stop by anytime you're in the mood for a cuppa.
Nice.
Oh, what's this?
Hey, what's this?
Oh, I got a scary mask.
Pop, pop, pop.
Tss, tss, tss, tss.
Alright, let's see.
We got a...
Oh, ow.
Oh, no.
The trees.
The trees are playing ping-pong, playing ping-pong with me.
Oh, I have to follow the path.
I can't just go wherever I want.
Okay, this way.
What happened to like the mama hamster?
I'd assume like...
Wait, what does the fuel can look like?
Is this a fuel can?
Oh, self is down.
Self is down.
I figured it out.
Oh, there's the mom.
I just missed the mom.
My babies.
They have once again disappeared.
Scattered, dispersed, non-existent.
Well, they probably hid somewhere around the dark.
Will you bring them back to me, crow?
My fur babies.
Please?
How many babies does she have?
Okay, still three.
Okay, she didn't make more.
Thank God.
I was worried she made more.
Alright, here we are.
Oh, hey.
Those are some gnarly beasts down there.
But I noticed they quite like our poop.
Maybe you can use that to our advantage.
What?
Are these zombies?
Are they gonna...
Oh my God, they're fucking freaks.
Oh my God.
They're zombies?
Did I do this?
No.
No, it can't be me.
Did I poop too much?
How do I put the fuel can?
Oh, here.
No.
It's never my fault.
The birdemic is real.
The radioactive poop.
No!
I am your creator!
You're not allowed to slap me!
What was this?
Oh, okay.
Poop.
Okay, nice.
I got out of that.
Alright, I gotta bring my fuel can over.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, we need one more.
We just need one more.
Woo!
Last one.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
And then we gotta find the babies.
I don't know where I...
Oh my god, I don't know where I left the babies on some of the areas.
Now we got us all the fuel we need.
I hooked up a few lanterns of generator while you were gone.
We just need to put them up on the four pillars around the camp.
Can you do that, little crow?
Wait, I have to do more?
I have to do more work for you?
What does that even mean?
Is that a pole?
Oh, that's a pole.
Okay, guys.
I learned what shapes are.
CrowKey has done it.
I have evolved.
I learned what pole shapes are like.
Can anybody stop this crow?
Yay!
I have to do more?
By golly, what an amazing little helper you are, CrowKey friend.
The camp is almost ready.
Just watch as I power on the generator.
Oh, I can just watch.
Nice!
I did it!
Yay!
Alright.
I completed the level.
I don't think there's anything I missed.
Yep, nothing at all.
Ha ha ha ha!
I think, I think I did it, guys!
I'm pretty sure I did everything I have to do here.
I didn't miss one single mission.
Oh, I got a cowboy hat.
Oh my god, wait!
New hat!
Children?
What kids?
Look, it's called Survival of the fittest.
If they don't survive, that's on them.
Alright.
They're only making it so that...
Okay.
Ha ha ha ha!
Is this Pyramid Head?
From the deepest... Oh, it is!
From the deepest depths of the subconscious world!
Ha ha ha ha!
Pyramid Crow.
Wait, where is he?
Yee-haw!
I want a yee-haw!
Halley, partner!
Be ashamed if you got pooped on!
Yee-haw!
It's Bounty Hunter Crow!
Ha ha ha ha!
I'm actually curious.
What is this?
Acre Allen Crow?!
Once upon a midnight deer while I pounded weak and weary over many a queen.
Oh my god, Acre Allen Crow.
Wait, what's this?
Riveria.
Be ashamed if... Okay.
Oh, it's Paris!
Ha ha ha ha!
It's fucking Paris.
Um...
I wanted to see what the other areas are.
Okay.
I want to see what Acre Allen Crow is like.
Guys, I found a secret level.
I know I said last level was like the final level, but like I found a secret level, guys.
It's like DLC.
Ah, bones.
Another haunted mansion?
I have a package for the guy living there.
Mr. Acre.
But that mansion is haunted.
With g-g-g-g-ghosts.
You think I'm stepping a foot in there?
No, sir.
I learned my lesson last time.
No more haunted mansions.
Do me a favor, will ya?
Scare that guy away.
So I can give him his package.
I really just need him to sign for it and then I'll get on with my route.
Alright, yee-haw.
Let's go.
Where is this?
Yee-haw.
I wanna see what Acre Oh my god.
You lost your babies again?!
Oh, because I never found him in the first place.
There's no again.
I just never found him.
It's working the night till death.
Okay, let's see.
I wanna know what the other missions are like.
Oh, hey.
Oh, is this Pac-Man?
I'm late for ghost school.
Nobody perform my ritual and I can leave until someone does.
Grab that salt bag and draw the shape, please.
Wait, what?
What's the shape supposed to look like?
Oh!
The triangle!
Oh, I see.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you, baby.
Don't worry.
Am I drawing it?
This is like that Mario Kart game.
No, I'm sorry.
Mario Party game.
Where you have to draw the line.
Don't worry, I got you, ghost.
Pew!
Heart attack.
Yeah, this is heart attack.
Is this a Triforce?
Why does this ghost need to draw a Triforce?
Oh, it looks exactly like the shadow marks.
I can now go to ghost school with all my other ghost friends.
I did it.
Beautiful.
I truly am made for art.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, what's this?
That's...
Wait a minute.
Did she...
Did she eat them?
Wait...
I didn't save them last...
This is what happened?
Wait, what does she say?
What does she say?
My babies!
They went trick-or-treating and dis...
Oh no!
Find them for me!
I baked you!
What did you do?
Were they the tree?
Ma'am, were they the tree?
I didn't save them for one day!
And now they're ghosts.
Oh my God.
Ew, what the fuck happened, Edgar?
What the fuck?
There's so many rats in here.
What are you doing, Mr. Edgar Allan Poe?
He's like in his bedroom, right?
Hello?
Am I scaring you?
Are you scared?
Why do I scare you?
Oh, I know.
Wait, he's not scared of me!
He's not scared of me!
Oh my God.
Wait, maybe this?
How is he not scared?
I'm a bird!
Hahaha!
Do I get the blanket?
Oh!
Can I be a ghost?
No, I can't.
God damn it!
Wait, unless...
No, okay, I thought I could like, knock it over.
Can I?
No, I can't.
No, I can't knock it over!
Wait, why aren't you scared of me?
I'm a crow!
Okay, what if I like, do like this?
Vroom!
No, he's not scared of me.
A human that's not scared of Croaky?
We gotta eliminate him.
Hahaha!
We gotta get rid of him.
We can't let this go to public.
Hahaha!
Oh!
Do you hear the whispers?
Do you hear ba-da-da-dum-ba-dum- dum-dum-dum.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's a spider here.
He's too dangerous to be left alive.
Wait, can I make this gaggle?
Oh!
Okay.
This isn't a defense.
Enter level threat.
How the fuck do I scare you?
What can scare you in your bedroom?
There must be something in here.
I will figure this out, Mr. Poe!
Where is it?
What the fuck can scare you?
I'm even wearing a cowboy hat!
Yee-haw!
Oh my god.
What if I just drop a fucking globe on him?
Alright.
No?
Oh, he's just annoyed.
I'm a crazy crow!
I'm wearing a cowboy hat!
I'm so fucking crazy.
I'm so quirky.
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
Is there anything in the mansion that I can use to scare him?
Where?
What do I do?
I've never met a person that's not scared of me before.
We have to eliminate him.
We can't have him procreating, creating other humans like this.
Oh, the whispers.
What do they mean?
These whispers.
I'm not like other crows.
Wait, this is actually a hard one.
What do they mean?
I don't understand.
I'm flying everywhere.
Is this?
Maybe he's scared of pies.
Maybe.
Oh my god!
Watch out!
A pie!
Are you scared now?
Watch out!
It's a pie!
Alright, maybe if I put the pie in...
Maybe if I just make more food?
Ow.
Okay, the soup doesn't like that.
Maybe I can grab a rat.
Is he scared of rats?
It's over for you, Edgar.
I'm gonna grab a rat.
I can't grab it.
I'm stuck.
No!
Do not let her cook.
It's so sad to scare him!
But I don't know what he's scared of!
I tried to grab this but it won't let me grab!
I tried to knock it off!
Boom!
I even pooped on it!
Can't grab the white sheet!
The mirror?
Is he gonna be scared of his own reflection?
It was the window.
I didn't even realize that was a window.
I did it!
I fucking did it!
It's the fucking window!
Alright, we're gonna see this time.
What do the poems say?
Hello, Edgar.
That's right.
You know what would be scary?
Your veggies!
No!
Not the veggies!
That's right.
Your house is haunted by croaky!
Wouldn't it be a shame if...
The lights went out!
Oh shit, sorry.
Wouldn't it be the shame if...
Your light source is gone!
Gross!
It's only the kitchen left.
Oh man!
Wouldn't it be a shame if...
Wait, what do I do here?
I...
I actually don't know.
What do I...
What do I do with this?
What?
The food's already contaminated.
What more does it need?
Wait, what?
What more does the food need?
It's already green!
I don't even need to do anything to that food!
The spoon?
Oh.
What if...
The pot suddenly stirred itself!
Oh, okay.
It's not that.
Alright.
I'll figure it out soon.
Apparently it's not that.
What the fuck do I do?
It's not the fucking pie!
That didn't work.
Yeah, it didn't work.
It has to be something with the cauldron because it's green.
Oh!
It was the glass of the...
Find a spooky costume?
Oh, this is over for you, Edgar Allan Poe.
It's over for you.
I am a ghost that you can this cat see through.
Yee-haw!
I did it!
It's a g-g-g-g-g-g-ghost!
Yay!
We did it!
We beat the game!
Nevermore.
We're not the bad guys.
We made him famous now.
Without me, Edgar Allan Poe would have died poor.
Now he's... well, he's still sort of died poor.
But like... but like, people remember him now.
I mean, he was so depressed and poor, but like...
but like, hey, at least he's famous now.
Like...
All I had to do was traumatize him.
That's fine.
People read his books.
Now high schoolers and middle schoolers have to read his books now.
Croaky was the one who got Edgar.
Croaky, please.
I made him.
You're welcome, Mr. Poe.
I made you.
Croaky made you.
Remember your... remember your origins.
I basically created goth kids.
You're welcome, goths.
You're welcome, goths and emo.
Edgar Allan Poe was the first goth kid.
And it's all because of Croaky.
What the fuck is... oh, okay.
We beat the game.
We beat the game, guys!
Howdy, partner.
Oh, my God, we did it, guys.
We beat the game.
Oh, my God.
I gotta drink some... some doking tequila.
Let me grab chat in real quick.
Oh, yeah, for those who...
For those who didn't... were not there for the beginning of the stream, I found a cool feature that I would like to show you guys.
Um, right here.
Ba-da-ba-da-bum, ba-da-bum-bum.
Ba-da-da-da-ba-da-ba-da-dum.
Ba-da-ba-da-da-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Ba-da-da-da-ba-da-da-da-da-da-na-na-na-na-na.
Ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-bum.
Ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba.
Ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-bum.
Anyway, that was my rendition of Bad Tomato.
I just... I wanted to show that.
I wanted to show...
I wanted to show Bad Tomato.
Um, but yeah!
That was fun!
I had a great time playing Jaws Crow things.
And I hope you guys had a great time watching me play.
Um...
It's a little bit of a shorter stream than you...
I mean, I did a lot of, like, 6-hour streams today.
Like, up this week.
So, like, this was a nice little, like, palette, like, cleanser.
A nice little chill hours with CrowKey.
Um, but I had a great time!
The very first 1440p stream.
I hope, like, the quality has increased a lot.
And I hope that it works for Wukong.
I might do another, like...
I'm definitely gonna do another, like, self, like, private test stream.
See if it helps with Wukong.
Like, the quality-wise.
But, like, I don't like how I used just Crow things as, like, the first 1440p stream.
The first HD stream.
With CrowKey.
Oh my god.
But maybe now.
My 1440p debut.
Maybe now.
The quality would be a lot better now.
Um, but yeah!
Thank you everybody for watching!
I hope you guys had a great time.
Um, enjoying the CrowKey hours.
Um, as always, everybody...
KAKA!
Stay hydrated.
KA!
And then, as always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Sorry, this was a translation for what I just said.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Yes, I'm bilingual.
I'm very fluent in Crowlish.
Um...
Anyway.
Bye-bye everybody!